hello everyone and welcome to a very
quickly recorded episode of play watch
listen um i was not going to make any
kind of intro to this episode but i
realize there are two things that i need
to say the first is that this whole
episode we talk about a tweet and i
realized that we never actually read the
tweet at any point meaning that um
anyone who didn't know about it who
wasn't on twitter or mr news is going to
be very confused by this episode so let
me take the time to actually read the
tweet to you
um troy baker tweeted this at
10 02 p.m january 13 2022 and the tweet
says i'm partnering with voiceverse nft
to explore ways where together we might
bring new tools to new creators to make
new things and allow everyone a chance
to own and invest in the ips they create
we all have a story to tell you can hate
or you can create what'll it be
um he's attached a jpeg to it it's some
sort of art of him
um
it looks i don't know nft and style and
the tweet has a tremendous amount of
engagement and has 11.2 000 quote tweets
and 1891 likes
and he is trending on twitter in a
number of countries i believe
the second thing is that i've only just
now discovered this literally a second
before recording this
there are uh some more
very negative very damning allegations
about the company that troy referenced
in the tweet that have come out but i
wanted to give the context that i did
not know about any of this and i imagine
the others didn't though i cannot speak
on their behalf as i we haven't spoken
about it but i personally did not know
about any of these things before we
recorded this uh regrettably or of
course i would have loved to have
brought it up but um that seems to have
come out a little bit later than this
conversation that we had started so but
that is it
to the episode i i also want to hand it
to you alana because at first i i i'll
be honest i i got a little afraid i was
like man when you said you wanted to do
kind of like a little disclaimer i was
like man i i don't burn me all right on
this because
there's there's no malice here and
there's so much other conversation about
this
in fact that we could do but my my
intention was just to say
hey
this was recorded earlier in the week
especially the goofy podcast that we
ended up doing it was a very he's gonna
title it something to do with wordle
it's just weird but it's also like and
and this is part of it that feels very
strange it's like i've so publicly been
against nfts to the extent that i was
like i should stop tweeting about this
because it's a bit much um i was like i
need to pipe down on my anti-nft tweets
that people are asking me for a
statement they're like you need to you
need to speak up about how you feel
about nfts i'm like just scroll my
twitter timeline for five minutes and
you've got that but it does feel like
something that i'm like okay i guess the
association is enough that i and again
this is a show where we've never even
pretended that we have the same opinions
but people are still asking for it so i
was like i would like to say
could i just point out how
unfair it is like this is this is
external to the issue we're obviously
talking about but it is incredibly
unreasonable how you're
i have no one has asked me to have a
public statement about really [ __ ]
hell yeah i just assumed it would happen
are you upset about that a little bit
mike
no that's not the point i'm making
troyes
the point i'm making is when these
things when these things happen and when
there's
let's say splash damage but that might
be too strong but like splash thing it
tends to fall down on on the women
i think that aspect of it's worth
pointing out that like
if if you're someone who who wanted
alana's take on this and not mine then
it's worth questioning also alan is much
more interesting than me and that's also
a reasonable reason i mean it's probably
that yeah it is probably though it's a
little thing i noticed but in any case
my intention was to was like i was still
gonna publish the episode but um
i was just gonna be like
hey this was recorded on tuesday but
also just so everybody knows i'm still
very against nfts and i would still like
to tweet something but i did want
th there's there's the fine line of me
like wanting to tell you try i really
still want to tweet just so everybody
knows i still [ __ ] hate nfts but i
wanted to tell you before i did that so
it didn't seem like a slight of you but
then when i was thinking about i was
like your tweet is still a slight at me
though you can hate all you can create
is technically a direct insult to every
person you know who has spoken out
against them and that's that's like a
difficult thing to that's why people are
so [ __ ] mad at you because i know
other people who are publicly involved
in nfts and people are like shut up bro
this one's a bit different
yeah that's man you you you nailed it on
the head and and especially for me
to
that the importance is that
unintentional or not it's still hurtful
it's it's not no it's it's hurtful not
necessarily to people it's hurtful for
the conversation because like you said
it's like hey either you and it was this
was not the intention
because i can guess what you would have
meant by it is the dumb thing that's
like i can guess
that's the thing is that you know me but
the fact is is i don't know 450 000
people
you know so but but this is being
broadcast out to those people i have to
be responsible about that and i have to
be like and and this is the problem we
just finished watching peacemaker and so
i was feeling you know i was like dad
let's have fun with this i was in a fun
place and i was like look there's a lot
of hate about this and my desire is to
create so what do you want to do here do
we do we want to do this do you want to
create i was trying to be inspiring as
opposed to what i figured i was like
he's trying
yeah
to
doesn't come off that way but it didn't
at all so um
the
sorry sorry troy it's good i think i
think that was the issue as well was
that it kind of mirrors um
a lot of the framing that's used by you
know crypto bros the the evangelists who
are kind of pushing this stuff
will be to kind of basically to dismiss
anyone and we've seen it in our own
comments section right when we talked
about it like to dismiss anyone who
doesn't agree with this even if they
have more experience or experts even if
they have more experience know the
systems they're talking about more are
programmers you know the they dismiss
those people as ignorant yeah and i
think that's i think that's what you you
may be tripped into there is yeah that's
that's that is the that is the go-to
terminology of of the worst proponents
for this this time yeah and that's so
antithetical to who i am which people
don't necessarily believe they think
that i can't take criticism and the the
truth is my job is to take criticism my
job
is to be told not only how to do what i
do but how what i'm doing is not right
and how i should do it better so if i
couldn't do that i wouldn't i'm pretty
successful at my job so i've learned how
to do that and i believe that the reason
why someone's telling me how to do
something better is because it is better
is because it is going to get a better
result so that's what i'm sifting
through right now everything is i'm
hearing the conversations from mike or
with you and other people that are
coming out to me going dude just to let
you know there's a few things that you
should be asking and what's so funny is
this maybe this shows my ignorance while
i understood that an nft was a component
to this that's not what i got involved
with i don't know how i feel about nfts
someone presented a platform to me that
said hey here's a tool that we're going
to be able to bring
valuable resources to creators
independent creators you want to work in
animation and video games or other
applications i was like [ __ ] yeah i want
to be a part of that because that's the
problem the thing that i've seen a
couple of people tweet about is like
troy's making his own job redundant what
an idiot and i was like well to be clear
he's worked with his technology before
this is not the first time that you've
had interest in this particular kind of
technology i think you also confuse
people with the image they thought that
you were selling images as nfts that was
the stupidest thing i could have done is
they sent that to me it was like hey if
you want to use this speaker i was like
yeah it's kind of fun
dumbass
for me to put the picture up
yeah
mate was also frozen right now
it was not a great pose
you're having internet problems if that
still happens that's the image
so try to dial back can i just ask you
like okay you know i i am a friend of
yours and i think nfts are trash and i
think they're exploitative and i think
they're entirely for profit that is my
stance and i think your tweet sucks
uh but i did want to ask like what is
this thing like i still don't have that
context i've seen their tweets which are
obviously like a company that's clearly
terrified um but i still don't
understand from your perspective what is
what is this voice verse nft what is it
uh making sure that i don't you know
nothing that they told me was
proprietary or confidential and
everything they have is up on their side
this company came to me and was like hey
we've created a you know we're an ai
company that's creating text-to-speech
but we wanted to make it you know no
robo voices and we also know that that's
typically a very
bespoke boutique higher end tool that's
that's reserved for top tier studios and
we want to make this available
to
independent creators and people who may
not be necessarily be able to afford
that and we're looking for people to be
able to supply voices for
that system would you be interested in
that and i was like yes and we had a
conversation about how does it we've
been going back for weeks about this so
this wasn't like some fly-by-night
person came to me and this was like uh
it was methodical and which shows that
even being methodical there's still
blind spots for this for me for me and
for for my whole team
um which i have to give credit to my my
agent she was like i don't know how i
feel about this one and there's a lot of
people there's like i don't know how i
feel about this like if the mitigated
risk is that people don't like what i do
i'm used to that but they don't know
i'm not going to sit here and virtue
single they have no idea like what
the intention that i have behind this
was like hey if somebody some some
independent game maker
wants to have me in their game and they
can't afford me and they can do that now
great
and he can own the rights to this and
and and own that in perpetuity that's
the problem right artists not being
supported
for for their art
that's what i wanted to do i was like
this is great
so again this is something that i've
seen you speak about on the before that
i think we spoke about the podcast
before um
and i've even seen
an nda video game where they sort of do
this with your voice
um
[Music]
but
i think the the question i have is like
from that angle or the way that they
tweeted things is does that not mean
that people can just make you say
whatever they want with your voice is
that not an issue sure but that can do
that right now like trust me if you want
to do
you can find me saying some stuff that i
i did not say did not want to say or
would never say
um
so that's my face is on porn so
yeah yeah they're already doing that
yeah
[Laughter]
mine's not are you okay my face aren't
important i left out for me the the
problem is is that they always put it on
a body that's better looking than mine
i'm like ah [ __ ] well i don't i don't
have that problem
so i mean i and
for me it's if i can if i can do that
that's what i that's what i wanted to do
and someone said well you're going to
put yourself out of a job my agent said
that just like are you not afraid of
putting yourself out of a job it's like
if this thing can put me out of a job
then it was always going to happen we
can't put the genie back in the bottle
you know what i mean so what i what i
want to do is i always want to work
towards a solution that is
bettering
um and mike and i had a great
conversation about some of the the
pitfalls and i understand i don't think
people are being vitriolic for no reason
i think that there's a lot of this that
um
has tremendous merit and so i've reached
out to the company and i'm asking this
and we're continuing that conversation i
don't know what's going to happen and i
told them that very specifically
um but what i do want to make sure that
i'm doing is that
the intention that i had is preserved
which is to help independent creators
that's that that still is there i want
to be able to do that
and if this is an avenue for me to do
that great if it's not i want to find
that avenue because i do still believe
in that and if the only reason why i
don't do something to help somebody out
is because it may hurt me that's a
[ __ ] up reason to not do the right
thing so if that means you can help
somebody but that means you're not going
to get something out of it that's pretty
shitty of me so if i lose out of a job
by giving somebody else one
how does that make me an [ __ ] i've
had that my whole life i've had people
be like you're giving people too much
help oh my god i don't care what i don't
so so i think the technology itself is
interesting like me and you have had
conversations like offline about like
again similarly nd8 stuff you know yeah
i've spoken to you before about it as
well mike and i also think that like
it's an interesting thing for um if
you're writing scripts for video games
that
it's a lot better than the regular robo
voice i think it's interesting i can
absolutely understand and i think
they're utterly reasonable the kind of
the concerns around especially like um
you know less experienced voice actors
maybe kind of let me move things the
good news is these technologies are all
[ __ ] which makes it a lot easier which
makes it a lot a lot easier from from
from that perspective and sorry
apologies these technologies in general
i'm at no point in this podcast going to
make a statement about this specific
partner that troy is working with any
criticisms applied
uh yeah i'm not i'm not going to talk
about any specific company in particular
because unfortunately generally nft
companies can be very litigious but not
specific ones
i i've just i've seen anyway that's too
happy yes my point is
the technology itself like most
technology is is without ethics until
it's used and i do think your desire
here to to as you say use use your voice
or give your voice as something that can
be used in certain contexts for game
developers is great i think uh the issue
is specifically the nft component which
is uh
completely unnecessary like and in terms
of agree and i i i just want to ask one
question before we get into the nft side
of it which i'm gonna get some i'm sure
we both have plenty to say about
so troy can i ask you just completely
candidly um and maybe it's the associate
association that i have in my brain with
nfts no part of your interest in this
was profit
was i paid or profit uh did did you
think that working with this company or
was part of your motive for working with
them that you thought that you would
tremendously profit
no
honestly would i am i making money off
it yes but this is not this is why i can
do stuff like this is because if it goes
great
fine but i'm not i'm not betting on the
[ __ ] here i'm not this isn't a
oh this could be a new revenue stream
for me this is because i have no idea
how it functions and it could
not work out at all and it could
we even had that conversation it's like
what does this look like long term
they're like let's see if this works if
it if it if companies don't tend to have
long term conversations true interesting
okay yeah they were like if if this if
this thing proves to be successful then
we can have an ongoing conversation i
was like okay and again i i i hope that
the my desire is not to break any kind
of nda but these were conversations that
were had with
under no auspices of of um
being nda'ed uh and i'm sure they would
would not i don't know they wouldn't
mind me sharing that with you
but no the the whole thing was not like
oh i'm gonna get rich quick that's not
what i do i i keep my head down and i
work really hard at my job um
and
i'm always looking
this is so weird
we had a conversation with our financial
planner because i started very very late
in life and if i could offer one bit of
unsolicited advice whether people want
to hear it or not right now is no matter
how old you are no matter how much you
have just
especially if you live in the united
states please put something away for
your retirement
just small amounts it could be five
bucks it's very very expensive to grow
old and die in this country and most
people do not have any plan in place
whatsoever for doing that and i've been
especially this last year there's been a
lot of people where that has become a
very real
uh component to their life and so i
started very very late in life and and
so i'm hustling right now to make sure
that if something were to happen to me
or something happens to pam travelers
looked after has nothing to do with my
wealth that has everything to do with
making sure that that kid gets every
opportunity that he deserves
so
that is what guides every decision that
i make
is is this good for my family is this
good for
him is he going to benefit from this
and
i have no idea if i'm going to have
another job ever again this this year is
looking good we have some great things
that are lined up and i'm excited about
that but beyond that i have no idea and
so i want to make sure that i am
investing in my future but it has is
never had anything to do and this this
would not be yet like i i have a mutual
fund and my financial planner has stuff
in place for that and that everything we
do i've even talked about this as like
hey man do we get into crypto he goes
absolutely not that's not your growth
plan because your growth plan is slow
and moderate and so everything that
we're designed for right now is being
very conservative and and not getting
into weird new things and so i get to do
that creatively whether it's be with
music or whether it be with games or
whether it be with companies that say
hey we've got new technology that could
maybe help new creators i'm like this is
not something that would have come into
the financial plan is the idea is like
that's that's what i thought i was like
either troy has been swindled by
passionate people because i can see troy
being swindled by passionate people
speaking about new technology
passionately or he's trying to make a
lot of money um
but i i guess your your answer is is
neither of those two it is alan you'd
back me up in saying that swindled by
you're speaking in the abstract there
you're not accusing any uh specific
company
yes in theory
by the way
not as much of an issue in the us though
i don't think
oh okay that's true yeah sorry
apparently so i see you okay
yeah you've got to be very careful yeah
at least with libel um
we have a wandering austin that is
welcome
check engine lights and getting my car
smog tested i thought you know what
could be more fun than this
watching my friend set the world on fire
well yeah and yourself right like i said
i texted austin and i was like i don't
know that tweet's gonna go down super
well for you you know what i just i
thought i was tempted to just drop into
this conversation make a sarcastic
comment and bounce out and see how that
goes no no no no i uh i i have to say
that today and i may tweet something
online about this one may just not do
anything but um
today it has been very revelatory in a
lot of ways and and
uh
one of the things that i've learned
today is that i may have lost a lot of
followers but i haven't lost a single
friend
uh and there are some days where you
could
it's like if you started pushing this
[ __ ] hot i'd be like buddy
like
the fact that you're willing to talk
about it will help you there but like
it's it there are you know massive
consequences to nfts i think
if friends came to me and and pointed
out to me the error of my ways
and
i didn't heed that and and
and that it would not be me that would
be losing a friend they would lose a
friend like they they would
does that does that make sense yeah you
take responsibility i would have to say
responsibility i'm the [ __ ] in that
component but what this has shown me
today is that there are people that
unless this is the beauty of of social
media and i hope everybody out there
hears this is that if there's things
that if there's conversations you don't
want to be a part of then get out of
them and if there's something that i'm
talking about that nobody wants to talk
about get out of it it's fine i
appreciate the unfollow it's not i'm
saying unfollow me baby i hope that
somebody would want to come to me and
have a conversation with me and a lot of
people have they're like hey man just
hope that you're really do it like what
mike did i hope you're doing the due
diligence on this and that you changed
your mind about this because of this
there's a lot of people that reached out
to me via text and that to me is a far
more personal thing
um
but i i again i just i'm i'm not an
idiot
uh um and i'm not um
i don't i don't know everything but i do
try to do as much
i'm not an idiot but i sure am dumb
sometimes
and i'm trying to learn and if if
there's anybody who wants to hold my my
feet to the fire for trying to be
smarter um that's that's not a friend
so my my friends have showed up for me
today um and a lot of them have called
me out and a lot of them have just
offered support and a lot of them have
said we've seen you do dumb stuff before
but i don't know if this is a dumb thing
i'm just wanting to find out more
information
um
so hopefully everyone out there can be
patient and if you don't be patient
totally fine the one thing i will say um
is uh
uh my family's off limits
yeah i'm not [ __ ] around about that
so i think that's completely reasonable
it is it is reasonable uh it's also
unreasonable for people to say stuff
about my family
so uh
leave my boy out of this
um mike i caught you off on what i uh
expected to be a very exciting spicy
rant but i don't remember please be a
spicy rancher no it wasn't a
particularly spicy ranch how would you
like your rant today medium spice please
sorry
fantastic it's a fan tonight as i said
to you i know what the [ __ ] does that
mean
we're past coffee and pepsi of this by
the way if you don't know that's kind of
like mike doing mushrooms
that is like yeah that is the extreme
um no all i was going to say and i guess
it's trying to be um
kind of being trying to be productive
with it because you know obviously yes
we chatted earlier and and i don't think
anyone on the pod or anyone watching
this podcast would be unsurprised that
i'm not a massive fan of the nft
technology um but the um
the thing i wanted to point out i guess
was
your stated aim you're kind of your goal
here of like i want to be a part of
these kind of pieces of technology that
can
you know theoretically help developers
and you know get your voice into other
things that maybe you wouldn't be able
to you wouldn't have the time you
wouldn't have the energy they wouldn't
be able to afford you whatever like the
the those it opens you up to other
people that's that's i think that's
genuinely like a good positive thing
i think what's interesting here and
again
it's something that consistently comes
up with the nft conversation whereby the
people who make these
uh tools and platforms
don't actually know how video games are
made and therefore massively
underestimate or overestimate the amount
of work required uh in order to do
anything
uh with with development tools
um it's not gonna surprise anyone in the
audience it's like opening your email
you have a username you have a password
you have two-factor authentication if
you're smart and you just develop using
tools in that way and there are other
tools which use similar technologies uh
text-to-speech uh with specific actors
and things which are essentially
paid for with licensing or something
that is accessible and something that
can be used without the enormous kind of
uh negatives of nfts um that are super
open i'd encourage you and i can we can
chat about this offline troy but like
the there are a lot of companies that do
that without needing to incorporate the
element here that i think people i don't
think i don't think a large portion of
the audience is i think there's i've
seen criticisms from voice actors but
i've not seen a massive frustrated
audience about that component i think
there is a way of doing that in a way
that is um ethical from like an
environmental point of view uh that's
absolutely something you could you could
go and i think if the goal you have is
to achieve that outcome you said i think
there are ways which is good news right
there are ways of doing that which which
i mean how do nfts
even really help this it's proof of
ownership right so it's essentially it's
like a login that's the only reason
you'd need an nfd in this occasion
and it's the other thing sorry that's
quickly worth mentioning and again not
talking about the specific company um
with an nf if any nft is just a bit of
consumer advice if any nft you're
thinking of buying
uh is actually allowing you access to a
server-based technology so something
like
a voice generation for example which
would require server-side tech
uh that nft will only function and work
as long as the company that provides
that service is in business or is
running that server so you do not own
anything in that occasion you don't get
with a jpeg if you buy a jpeg knock
yourself out you're going to be able to
own that jpeg in the same way as i can
own that jpeg have a great time but when
your nft is access to a server you're
not buying permanent anything
um and there is no uh
i get that the the blockchain is um and
i i think blockchain technology
specifically is interesting um
not nfts i know i get that the
blockchain is a public ledger but even
when it comes to jpegs aren't they still
just hosting on a server that still has
the ability to go down you're right but
the difference is you can grab a jpeg
download it and you have exactly what's
on the server i mean that's true
if the servers if it's a process where
you're generating something you know
today you want troy to say i don't know
something racist
for the internet everybody goes to that
by the way there's never been a
deviation there's the one thing that you
like what if you say that you hate i was
like whatever we've been on the internet
um but no the point is like someone gets
something generated now with with troy's
voice um that requires them to upload a
bit of text some stuff happens on the on
the cloud on the server they get the
audio file back
if the thing on the server's not there
you can never get new stuff you can you
can keep the wab file you've got of troy
saying
an awful word but you can't like get
more stuff going forward so the service
is not ongoing now and to be clear the
same is true of every
the nft conversations is a lot of it's
like oh but i can buy this thing and own
it indefinitely until they don't support
it like there's no re the blockchain
doesn't fix these problems
to be fair this is also true of any
other service the only difference is
that they're pretending to when i pay
exactly when i buy a unity license no
one at unity says by the way you will
own this forever right like there's not
that there's not that lie even when you
buy a dvd it has a little flyer in the
box that says this is you know the legal
stuff over here allana because you you
mentioned it every now and again the the
legalese of you don't really own this
film it's always printed in the box um
that's there's an inherent kind of
from nft companies in general dishonesty
around
around how that's presented is there a
basic level of consumer protection
that's possible there though that
basically says
if i
buy
like like a user agreement basically
that essentially says i
uh i recognize that if your servers go
down
you know
like that is a known scenario
which would
you know
whether that's like this the simple
layman's answer would be
you know that there's
like a refund a refund like a transfer
of title back kind of thing like isn't
that solvable through something in that
i'm not saying that it would be if the
law was applicable to any of these items
yeah from my i don't mean i don't mean
enforceable necessarily i don't mean
that that is a legal i don't mean like
consumer protection in the sense of a
government uh
agency i just mean in this in the sense
that
can't that be something that is insisted
upon as a as a like user license
agreement yeah yes
i think the nft fans currently are
trying to suggest because it helps with
the shilling of nfts that that is just
not a problem with their particular
technology like they're like we don't
need this you own it no matter what the
blockchain is the thing that that they
keep
defaulting to because they don't want to
admit that that could potentially be a
problem at least that's my perspective
um and i think it's also that a lot of
these companies right now are
effectively operating like startups so
there aren't just a lot of regulations
like if there were to be some government
level consumer protections i don't think
that they've hit the nft companies or
any of the blockchain yet really
it's just not there yet and the reality
is it's against a company's interest to
tell you
if they don't have to
no yeah that's why i was saying it would
have to be an insistent upon part like
on the part of the consumer i'm not i'm
not i'm not proclaiming that that exists
or even that it could exist and that
could be a fatal flaw of
this but i was just
yeah what you're saying makes perfect
sense and sounds awesome and i i think
the reason that they aren't doing that
again is that they would then have to
admit that things aren't permanent just
because they're on the blockchain but
you know things can't be hidden forever
this is where i this is where i i
it's so the last 12 hours or what not
even
what is so
forgiving i have no clue what the first
20 minutes of your conversation
consisted of but i like drinking fanta
i'm on to my third bottle it's uh oh my
god multi-pack over here that's not true
at all
i'll tell you what's non-fungible my
diet nice
um
what is so
it's not a revelation but what what um
what's just such an interesting
spotlight on the way that i operate
relative to apparently lots of other
people
is i like to ask questions and be
curious and to learn things and it is
interesting how every now and again
things will
flip a switch that just invalidates all
forms of that immediately and so i've
said this to troy already
and apologies for just saying this again
but i think that troy himself prevented
that by saying you can hate or you can
create he himself
said i will not be taking any questions
you're a hater i don't want to hear it
by tweeting well it's not i know you
wouldn't have done that intentionally no
no but it's it's to me it's it's it's
more than i would take it a step further
it's not i will not be taking any
questions it is if you if you if you ask
a question if you ask a question
you yeah so this is what's so funny is
that's so antithetical to me
that had i give it a second look i i
probably would have gone and i even
looked at it i was like
nah this be it'll keep it light it'll
keep it fun that's the thing that's
where i that's how i read it like yeah
again that was but you know twice
friends even i read that and was like i
was like i know i think this is one of
the stupidest [ __ ] tweets i've ever
read troy but even i think that that's a
that's a step too far because you've
read some stupid [ __ ] tweets true
people have said some [ __ ] to me but in
any case i was still like i know what
troy was trying to say but i do not
fault anyone else for not knowing that
because it's such a specific
troy way to communicate that like i
don't i don't think it should have been
assumed that everyone else would
understand what he was trying to do yes
just i i for me i will never i will
never empathize with the instinct that
says
this is maybe not meant for levity
therefore
epoxy doesn't it doesn't really
it doesn't read as a joke it's even if
it's not like it sounds like i mean i
agree nobody should be sending him death
threats to saying that they want him to
die um the scale of this is surprised me
but i don't think it's that that people
are reading it
yeah you're still trending um i don't
think that people are reading it as how
dare you make a joke about nfts people
are reading it as you are selling a scam
that is hurting the environment and you
have the audacity to call me a hater
when i would even
preemptively before i've even criticized
you
he's attacked everybody who disagrees
from the jump look i i i i'm not a fan
of false dichotomies uh but uh
but um still even the way you phrased it
just then
is uh a far more
you know even keeled just sort of like
it's i mean look it's i know it sounds
like i'm describing that i've never
heard of twitter and how people act
um it's not that way it just still
always baffles me because it's just
i don't know what it would take for me
to send
a message like i mean even my stupid
little joke got piled on yeah yours
yours was troy's was not surprising to
me yours was like uh
look i'm not here i'm not super clearly
joking and i'm not i'm not um
trying to be a victim or anything it's
just been hilarious that i look at it
and i go
you know
here's something down folks like yeah
here's something that i realized today
is that uh twitter doesn't have a
maximum of 248 characters it has or 240
characters has a maximum of 258 because
tacitly to everything i post
there is the
what do you think attached to it like i
understand if i post something
i can't just expect someone to not
comment on that but
isn't what everyone did today tell you
what they think 100 yeah so that's
that's why i can't get mad it's it's
ridiculous for me to go what do you
think well i don't want to hear what you
have to think
by tweeting it you're asking their
opinions yeah absolutely i'm putting it
out there i'm showing my ass and
someone's going to go you're showing
your ass
or and and by the way the
the clear distinction right now and man
i'm really glad
look i i have made a career out of
failure
and let's just put all in perspective
guys i'm i'm used to getting hate
i did the silent hill 2 remake
all right i'm used to this
but the
um
the thing that i learned today is that
it's okay to [ __ ] up it's okay to make a
failure to sit in that and and not do
anything if if i didn't go ah well
people can think where they're going to
think
there's no growth from that at all so
the thing that i'm most grateful for is
that whether they're friends or just
followers whether they're people that
just happen to come across it because
someone else retweeted or whatever to
point out is like hey man let me tell
you what you just did by saying this the
perfect example
i had i had this time when i was um
i was i was trying to be more optimistic
um and i was trying to
de-catastrophize my own language
uh by not saying it was a nightmare i
was devastated i was saying i'm
challenged right now i'm being stretched
right now because i was finding myself
it wasn't good for my mental health and
it was just it was perpetuating myself
into this negative space i was trying to
be more optimistic so if somebody said
something negative to me i would say
cool
oh man okay cool like i understand i i'm
here with you but i'm not trying to go
oh that's [ __ ] the worst thing i've
ever heard before because i was trying
to de-catastrophize the problem is
is that i said that to someone who had
just lost their daughter and she goes
i'm really having a hard time right now
i'm struggling and and i have to go
plant a few and i was like
okay cool
and that did not land well
and now i look back and i was like what
i was trying to do where i was i was
trying to make that person in the same
place and so
saying i hear you i understand tell me
how you feel
um
okay
is is a much better thing to say than
cool so i had to change my vernacular so
today was a good opportunity for me to
learn where my vernacular and the way
that i'm phrasing things regardless of
the intention behind it
i have to still be responsible for for
what is said
where it is said and to whom it is said
um and so to everybody out there
regardless of what you said
um
i i want you to know that i really uh i
thank you for your patience i thank you
for the opportunity to to learn
to hopefully this is what i try to do
the entire my entire life
is learn how to tell my story better
learn how to speak better
and i learn new words and and i get [ __ ]
for it sometimes but i want to do that
because i just want to learn how to
effectively communicate and so today i
really recognize the fact that me trying
to do that was just a [ __ ] bad look
and everyone who said that was a shitty
thing to say you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right and i apologize
for that um i wish that i had phrased it
differently
and i welcome people's thoughts about
about this i want to learn more about
this technology i want to learn more
about this space i want to learn more
about how people feel about this well
that's part of it that i wasn't sure of
until talking now um
[Music]
so it this tweet is not actually
intended to be in support of nfts
you you're working with this company and
you still don't really even know that
much about nfts but you weren't working
with them because of the nft component i
was working with them because they have
a platform that i like that is being
able to we i i said specifically as like
i want to make sure that we're clear
like what i'm what i'm into this for is
the fact that you have a platform that
can give resources to independent
creators and and they were like yeah i
was like now i want to be a part of that
and and it struck me as the exact same
as the tina guo sample library like it
it it
yeah yeah or
comparable at least what is that
so like for composers
you know you you buy these sample
libraries that let you kind of create
you know a fake orchestra
or or you know electronically rendered
versions of real instruments and and the
the old days it was you know done with
synthesizers and then they started
creating samples where you literally
record like a violin one note at a time
and then when i play it on my keyboard
it's it's calling all those recordings
in real time that's how sample libraries
work and so somebody started realizing
we can make branded ones of these and so
like the cellist that i worked with tina
guo she they took her into the studio
and recorded you know her on her cello
one note at a time you know it takes
days it's really tedious work but you
can go buy on cinesamples.com you can
buy
uh the tina guo sample library and it's
really her playing and the i and people
looked at her and go aren't you
basically eliminating your own work and
it's like the people that are going to
use this probably couldn't afford to
hire me
and
and and and also like she was also she
uses these tools herself because she's
also a composer so she was like i also
don't really like most cello sample
libraries so i'm going to try to bring
something to market that i think
improves on what's out there and then
all these people will be able to use you
know my sound uh in a vastly you know
like and i went from having 10 clients
to to 10 000 in a sense
um asked an academic question based on
that actually um given that so samples
like samplings existed like that for
what decades yeah has there
do
do modern musicians
dislike it do other people who are like
this is taking away jobs from musicians
really there are some they always say
that but you know i don't know that
there's much evidence of that i mean
it's hard to say because the the kinds
of productions that use samples like a
lot of tv never record never records a
live orchestra they just use the samples
because they're like we don't have the
time first and foremost because we have
to like score an episode in three days
but also or [ __ ] covid right where all
of a sudden you oh there's another yeah
like there's always circumstances but
it's definitely stratified by budget but
the great thing is you know like
spitfire it changed the industry though
right presumably that invention or the
first time they sold it yeah that would
have messed up well not me sorry messed
up implies negative altered the
economics on like a global scale of the
music industry and it also made it
available to other people like who knows
but it's understandable why that would
you know be intimidating or scary to the
voice actor and community in the same
way right like it's understandable that
they would see that coming it's far and
away a net positive because you go from
the reality is instead of fewer people
hiring voice actors it's more games
incorporating voice like i just think
you know there's a lot of games that
would say we don't have a viable way to
hire
anyone but we have a you know like the
banner saga was one where they said
we're gonna go text because voice is is
completely impractical given the sheer
amount of lines we've got like to me
though in those conversations yeah like
not to derail i was in a meeting about
this not at sms but i'm meeting about
this literally last week with um a
studio
who was like we don't want to use the
robo voice but it's not a good use of
our time to have people in-house record
all the dialogue what are our options um
so i definitely i get that and i also i
also understand like smaller voice
actors concerns with it too i imagine
that the similar for the composing
community like i would guess people are
split on it some people like it and some
people don't it's just i don't see now
it's it's not it's
i can't speak for what's going to happen
ten years for even five years from now
but if if you're
if you're wondering if this is going to
take that job away from you
there's there's a larger concern at play
um because you can't
if you're banking on that job that this
could potentially take away from you to
make your rent
you're you're living too high from the
ground like there there's there's far
other more concerning questions that you
need to have at play i i say that
because that's me too if i'm waiting if
i don't have the ability to sustain
myself if i don't get another job i
better go out and get a different job i
got [ __ ] a family to feed it's the
equivalent of saying if there is a if
there is a machine learning algorithm
that can analyze a screenplay and then
really viably write a new one derived
from that if a screenwriter looks at
that and goes
you took my job it's like you your job
is to be better than that is
uncomfortable i think the the four of us
on this call should
it's it's tricky for us to comment on
like what things are like at the the
just starting out stage of all our
careers right because we're all quite
quite far removed obviously have name
brands and well hold on
are not not as we're not impervious but
we're we're more removed from the kind
of automation that presumably is coming
for
all kinds of jobs i agree we are not
specifically in competition with that
automation where other people may be i
don't know man yeah see i'm not entirely
sure that that's the case maybe i am
because in some ways i'm more the
reticle's more on me than anybody else
because
you say something daft on twitter and it
trends for 12 hours you're you have a
audience right i have an audience and
and the the point that i'm making is
that
they're not where it's like any company
when there's big change you never you
never fire like the middle management
you fire the the most expensive that's
where the change happens and so
the person that the the uh
producers by and large are looking for
is like how can we get away from hiring
someone like troy baker who's really
expensive versus that guy doesn't cost
that much he's a negligible amount or
she's not going to be as expensive
so what i what i'm saying is they're
trying to if they're trying to bring
anybody's costs down it's not that
person it's me
um so i i agree my job is to be
my job is it's not be better than
anything my job is to be the solution to
the problem and if it comes to the point
to where it's like troy you're too
expensive you're too used you're not
good enough the the industry has changed
and we're not hiring dudes like you
anymore
it's not this industry owes me nothing
there's no job that i am owed or deserve
everything that i've been given i've
worked my ass for and someone has been
kind enough to give me an opportunity
period i don't deserve [ __ ] what i do
what i deserve and if anything else
today showed you i deserve [ __ ]
but anybody that gives me anything after
that is grace and i would much rather
err on the side of that so my job is i
is this analogy a lot you cynicism sure
or or skepticism
skepticism and criticism i just can't
abide that bad faith takes from from
from folks
i know i look i know it's just my job to
abide i didn't i see him in nature but
it just by it bothers me when people are
sure i didn't see i didn't see
everything troy received i don't think
anything i mean some of it could process
that [ __ ] some of it
and to be clear anyone sending threats
or whatever [ __ ] you but most of the
takes i saw on the subject i didn't see
many what i would call bad faith
arguments from troy's way i saw people
either
either people sending him personal abuse
which is pointless or people who were
raising i saw a lot of people raising
kind of the standard kind of reasonable
concerns about this technology right i
wouldn't say it's bad faith i'm not
making a blanket statement that
therefore all the takes were bad takes
either i'm just saying those that were
they i have a i have a
um it i have a i don't know it's a it's
a soft spot when i just don't like when
people don't engage when people want to
talk more than listen and assert an
opinion that they don't actually
um they're not interested
in anything remotely approaching
dialogue and i get that social media
especially twitter above all is
especially inconducive to that so like i
again i recognize that i sound just like
some
weird blend of a naive child who's never
seen twitter before i mean yeah so as i
said before i think there are two sides
to this that i do think that again i
think
i don't want to like go on this too hard
but i think what troy said
is hostile he is starting the hostile
conversation so hostile responses come
from disagree with me baby might have
been a better signal yeah
100 well first of all
man i there's there's so many different
drafts of this trust me that i that i
could think of
um
that would be far
uh there's other you know it
i don't know man i don't know that we
need to even talk about the tweet part
of it any more than than we have but i
think like yeah if people are
threatening your family they can go [ __ ]
themselves no matter what you say like
absolutely [ __ ] that but i i do also
think that
um
treating people
austin i think your discomfort with the
bad faith is like i feel like troy's
tweet is in bad faith and and thus is
being
how so with those responses i think you
can hate all you can create is oh oh
that part oh sorry i just want to make
sure because i didn't think that was the
bad faith
it's probably not the right way to say
it but i mean in the same bracket in
terms of conversation it is it it serves
the same purpose as the bad faith tweets
in in terms of
i can i can fully acknowledge that i can
agree that that that uh
that the frame the phrasing
made it easy i suspect to have a bad
faith
fair enough i think what kind of bad
faith responses you saw austin
yeah
like well i mean i'm terrible at
recalling off the top of my head that
which i as soon as i saw thought i wish
i had never seen that but the kinds of
things where someone would say things
like
um
uh well this is the joking one that i
saw so i i fully acknowledge is a
horrible example to use because i know
they were joking
um but there were so many that were so
razor thin close to this that were not
joking that that i saw just in a simple
personal even just within my
notifications in the tiny subset the the
small offshore sandbar that was the
island of this
um
the the somebody somebody i
i wrote what i thought was clearly a
joke i was not making a claim in any
direction i just simply made a joke and
one person actually saw exactly how i
meant it where they were like
you know essentially saying you're going
to go write a bunch of kai lang fanfic
and be able to use choices i've 100 of
you what you meant i was like that's all
i was picturing is like just
silliness because that's to me twitter
is like you were trolling your friend
and you were pretending that you were
gonna make him say stupid [ __ ] i mean
that was really clear and i
yeah that was all my stake in it but my
favorite was
just all these people being like you
know
uh
uh you know oh man you know there there
there goes you know i guess i i guess i
used to like your music or whatever and
there was but there was one that i saw
where again i know they were i know they
were kidding but they said somebody goes
dude he was kidding and they go oh in
that case journey's good again
look i actually left but i also was like
the thing is there's a lot of folks out
there that that's not that wild of a
tank that they would have it was like
this poisons everything that you're
attached to because i've decided this is
inherently poisonous
and i'm like but that's not
that's not engaging with anything that's
just that's like that's like a scarlet a
you know that is so engaging so engaging
is one thing and asking questions is one
thing i do i do agree with you that
should be the default state but surely
there's a point where you have engaged
you have investigated you've
looked into it you've looked around
you've asked questions maybe if you have
a direct line to someone
where you do
you you've done all of that and you go
this kind of sucks like i don't really
there's definitely like i can think of
like actors who i don't particularly
want to see in movies anymore because i
know what their opinion of jews is right
like that that comes up
more than it should yeah like you know
there's there's i mean that's an
interesting thing
you know that's kind of it by the way
troy has wonderful opinion of all people
i feel loved did you point that out i
contextualized what i just said
like i do i do i celebrate those
holidays too just because i can
understand someone who was
so upset to find out that um troy was
working in the nft space that that does
have a negative impact on that's
something that i distinctly want to
point out i want i do want to
distinguish
reasonable and that's probably true yeah
there's there's a feather that's been
floating around this particular topic
for a while so i won't address it it it
reminds me of the say it ain't sojou
well if you're not um uh familiar say it
so it was it was a phrase that a kid
said to uh shoeless joe jackson after
learning that shoeless joe had thrown
the the world series
um and i think that
the the reason why they became such a
phrase is because it tainted that kid
that kid became everybody for about
baseball because it tainted something
that was considered america's pastime
and this holy you know uh uh a wonderful
and pure thing so there are a lot of
people and there's even pulling up one
who said um
i'm really disappointed and man
disappointed i can i can take anger and
i can take um
a lot of other vitriolic words but um
when someone says like you're the reason
why i got into this business which first
of all if i can inspire someone else to
tell their story in however many ways
that that that is my ultimate dream
that's my ultimate goal more than
anything more than daredevil
um but if i if i in turn
um do something that that in some way
pulls not necessarily me down a peg
uh but but in some way
changes their perspective and and
disillusions them from their own passion
man that's that's that's me again
antithetical to every everything that i
that i want to do so uh to to those
people as well i i i want those are the
those are the tweets that kind of
raised above the den more than the
others and cut through the mire uh more
than others and to those i i i
appreciate you very
succinctly and cogently expressing how
you felt about that and then you had the
balls uh to
to express that to me that that says a
lot i've i've
telling someone that you like their work
is easy telling someone that you're
disappointed in them is really really
hard and so if you did do that
behind the screen name of anonymity or
not i i do appreciate that and i i want
you know i do hear that um
i just always want to encourage civil
um and an informed conversation
i just don't know man sometimes it's
like you know it's it's sometimes just
not worth it and and i this may be a
situation where it's it's just not worth
it like i what i was trying to do and
and
the the dreams that i had to to to take
this and what this could have meant may
kind of fall by the wayside and and
we'll talk about that offline because it
doesn't matter but i'll give you i'll
give you a good faith promise that i'll
help you find another way to do this
without
the nft involvement i'll i'll make it my
personal mission to help you with that
for sure thanks man if that's something
you want to do yeah i always want to
find ways to help people
you know i totally think it's doable i
think there's a lot of places that would
love to help you with that
and
wouldn't be using technology that's that
isn't inherently untrustworthy as part
of it is that i think that you could
probably do this in a way that like if
you too were to do it um in a way that
is in the interest of protecting
creators and protecting voice actors as
well um again this does feel like a
conversation that should be had
elsewhere but um sorry apologies i
shouldn't have gone there it's okay
somebody being tied to nfts to to me is
inherently i'm like i don't trust this
technology it's trying to take people's
money um
but
yeah that that seems like a separate
conversation um i
to to kind of
tag on to what mike was saying i by no
means mean for this to be this is more
you know i'd be surprised by this i want
to keep the focus on me
uh and kind of like how i write you how
are you
troy baker while i'm trending i'm going
to take advantage of your 23 000.7
tweets oh my god you have more than pete
davidson
oh [ __ ] and almost as many tattoos
um i mean i tell you who's breathing a
sigh of release
is joe rogan tonight he was like i don't
know who the [ __ ] troy baker is actually
he's still at the top to be fair uh oh
yeah yeah
uh but no i to to piggyback off what
mike says like this is about how i
[ __ ] up and and how i could have
framed this better and and to uh to let
everybody out there know if you're
watching this and hopefully you are so
you always give someone opportunity to
um uh
make amends
as it were or at least hear another side
of it that hopefully can make you
you know
more informed
more empathetic maybe a little bit uh is
that this is about me so i i do want to
be very careful that i'm not uh
keeping the reticle on me yeah um
so that's that's smart right yes um troy
can i ask like in relation to all of
this like what what do you personally
know about nfts how how much knowledge
well [ __ ] i learned a lot more today
more after our channel
yeah
doing a lot to work there mike what do
you what do you know now troy uh what i
do know now is that i i i see
i see the appeal and i see the disdain i
see both angles of how someone could
look at this and go this is a wonderful
tool uh to be able to use i don't think
that they are inherently bad i think
that very few things in this world are
inherently bad uh talk to oppenheimer
and he will say the same thing it's the
ability to use something for good it
could have powered the that energy could
have happened
yeah i was like
he sort of knew
when he saw how it was being used
absolutely he said behold i become death
the destroyer of worlds but the reason
why he was doing it was to hopefully
provide an energy source that could
sustainably power the entire world so i
think that being able to i can't wait
for people to take that one out of
context
you were this close baker
actually i don't think that's an
unreasonable analogy
of course
it may as well be on the same level that
that's what's interesting about it like
is that true like do you genuinely
believe there's the amount of vitriol
around troy as there was around no
around nfc nuclear weapon no no no i
mean nfts are so ideologically
polarizing that and like in crypto by
extension that there are things where
like no matter what
one is
what's
what someone says about it um
it's sort of like it it gets it gets
pulled into a vortex of of you know i
don't hear anything you're saying it's
just this is again i i i think you're
right and i think that nuclear power is
treated the same way even though
i don't love this parallel and would
kind of like to move away from it just
in general but i don't disagree with you
that i think today after post this tweet
i think talking about nfts is going to
be even harder um and my stance is still
that i currently really dislike uh the
way they are being implemented i am i'm
very against it but i'm always
interested in new technology um and i'm
always interested to see
what people can do with the blockchain i
had i had played a an early um
blockchain based game and was was
interested in the skin economy in that
game and what they were going to do with
it and it's gotten to a point now where
it does feel like we can't even have
those conversations that's all that
happens
i can just i just plus one to to that
comment because that allow me to minus
one to that i i i think all nfts are
terrible we shouldn't do them i think
i'm in agreement regarding nft
specifically is that's not what you said
though it's blockchain more so that
sorry yeah i just speak
i think i think until the technology can
be done
more safely and until it can be until it
can do something that regular server
tech can't i'm i'm in agreement right
now it serves i don't believe that it
serves any any function but i don't like
the idea that we can't have the
conversations about potential functions
whatsoever um but i'm in agreement i do
not currently think that it serves any
beneficial purpose even the public
closure is not something that that i
think is is enough um what do you think
are good ways to move the conversation
forward i'm just curious as we wrap up
[ __ ] me how what is a good way to move a
conversation about nfts forward
yeah
stop have it off twitter
well no no i'm just saying i'm just
saying you you said i do the thing that
you hated about this
don't want to mischaracterize what you
said but is that this kind of hurt the
conversation about it so
what do you think and help the
conversation
um
the entire reframe of the system as they
exist right now they have a negative
impact on the environment and serve to
make people money and do not serve a lot
of public interest um and i think the
reframing of that like you can take this
this concept
and uh rethink it and i'm sure that
somebody will in a way that is
not as negatively impactful i think that
is the solution to having reasonable
conversations about it whereas i mean
maybe it's i said to someone today it
was like how you how are you feeling
about all this i was like maybe um troy
to use the analogy that we're using that
i hate uh nuking himself will make some
of these triple a publishers look at it
and go oh
we probably shouldn't do that and i was
like that could be a plus
like cynically and for getting you know
my friends involved i think troy you did
more to help halt the nfc you may have
killed it
i'm gaming today
in history you may have genuinely saved
a lot of publishers
that's what i was like publishers might
have seen it and and now we'll be like
right now he thinks he's the messiah
great
he didn't already have a big [ __ ]
hell he's a savior of one but it's it is
it is entirely possible that that that
this going this big um and getting this
backlash will have made
just sit the [ __ ] down oh god this is
the worst possible outcome what have we
done yeah
hey you did this
jesus stop
stop speaking
stop
it may have made people who are very
involved in this space or even curious
about it um they're like oh [ __ ] this is
why this is bad people really don't like
this we should back out and and
again i think the the thing that helps
the conversation is
uh a massive pivot off of the way that
the technology is currently run
yeah here's what ultimately the
conversation's fueled by the facts of
the technology you have to change the
facts in order to make it a possibility
yes that's a much more succinct way of
saying let's try to say thank you change
the fact you did draft one you did draft
one it was very good i took draft two i
punched it up a bit now we just need to
get someone to put a joke in there and
we're fine i do have to say that even
though there were some fun moments in
what would have been
this was supposed to be a disclaimer and
i think this is probably going to be the
episode yeah um what would have been the
the the previous episode that was done
on tuesday sometime i might have stopped
this episode yeah there's some fun ones
i think hold it back usually that's like
that's that's the mid-season break there
was some fun moments in it but uh
i i i do appreciate this is this is why
i think we started this whole
podcast conversation thing is is for
four people from disparate views uh in
some sometimes disparate locations to be
able to um have a conversation that all
four hopefully walk away from i know i'm
walking away uh feeling more enlightened
and and
and lighter so thank you for talking to
us about it troy like i was also worried
that like talking to you about this
would potentially be bad for your mental
health it's like i don't know how
this is going to lead to it man i
thought that you would want to do that
regardless to be honest but but thank
you for talking about it i think this is
an important thing for us to talk about
um information is key i was i was just
talking to this about with my physical
therapist is like if not having
information is the worst thing that you
can do uh having information is is is
empowering and and critical so i always
want information
um
[Music]
yeah i i
i i can only echo the sentiment that
that um
my favorite responses to this podcast
that i see from people is
when they are like it's nice that there
exists little corners of the internet
where people can disagree or not even
disagree as if minds are made up but
just explore an idea in a collective way
where we're throwing we're each throwing
our incomplete picture of the story on
the middle of the table
[Laughter]
this close
discuss it with me baby
no it's it's it is cool i think it means
a lot to your character troy that you
you you want to talk about it and you
want to talk about it in a public way i
think that's yeah thanks guys i um
i i appreciate all of you and i feel
like i want to cut this on oppenheim
for the record i thought that i was
popping into the last two minutes of a
thing so i just in no way recorded my
audio i have your audio so that show you
guys
we all have your audio hello everyone
three etherium nice yeah [ __ ] off
we want you to jesus christ troy's
influence uh hello everyone and welcome
to play watch listen i'm alana i'm a
video game writer that is mike bithell
he is a video game director that's
austin winter he's a video game composer
and that that and that's troy baker
who's trending on twitter
we will see you all next week bye